nearly six months after the fall of
helsin with winter approaching there's
been a surge in fighting
why has the southern city taken by
russia in the first few days of the
invasion become the latest focus of
fighting
strategically hurston is important in
this war for two main reasons it's a
vital stepping stone for russia if it
plans to attack the strategic port of
odessa 200 kilometers to the west
and when russia annexed crimea in 2014
ukraine cut crimea off from the national
grid and also stop vital supplies of
fresh water
this explains russia's focus on
zapariccia a major source of electrical
power and helsin which controls the
supply of fresh water
so russia will not want to lose hereson
and has been moving troops from the
donbass to reinforce its forces in the
city
in response ukraine has blown up three
strategically important bridges across
the dinipro river linking russian
occupation forces with their resupply
options
isolating the russian soldiers and
eroding their morale
ukraine has also targeted ammunition
depots far-shed aircraft and military
facilities in southern crimea
however to retake hersen you need either
overwhelming numbers of troops or need
the element of surprise
the ukrainians appear to have neither
but we should not underestimate the
potential for the local population to
assist expelling the russian forces
so why amounts and operations liberate
helsin now
after six months of war if ukraine is to
prevail it needs to seize the initiative
president zielenski also needs to
bolster hope and inspire the nation
new weapons are arriving from the west
providing ukraine military greater range
and greater precision there is a small
window of opportunity before the autumn
rains arrive which will not stop the
fighting but will limit military options
the relatively poor showing of the
russian military is also causing issues
for russian commanders and there are
reports of an apparent rift between
vladimir putin and his defence minister
sergey shoigu who has been imposed for
the past 10 years
the defense minister is often seen in
military uniform with numerous medals
but he has no experience serving in the
military
so with russian forces stalled russian
leadership failing this is a timely
window of opportunity for president
zielinski to seize the initiative